foreign
this boat isn't going to an exotic
holiday destination
it's taking us to Obi Island to get a
rare look inside one of Indonesia's
largest nickel plans this Factory is key
in the global nickel supply chain
Indonesia is by far the world's largest
producer of the metal an essential
component for Batteries That Power
electric vehicles around the world
but getting the nickel out of the ground
is Dirty Work an environmentally
conscious consumers may not be fully
aware of how polluting it is to obtain
the metal the pickle for the EV makers
is how do we get this nickel that we
need without hurting our reputation and
also without hurting the environment
we take an inside look at nickel's
growing importance and the environmental
toll it leaves behind
nickel is used in batteries because it
increases in ev's range batteries with
lots of nickel can run farther than
batteries that don't use the material
nickel is the cheapest and the highest
energy density and that's why increasing
nickel is a goal of ours and really
everybody's in the energy in the battery
industry
for years nickel had been sourced from
countries such as Canada and Russia
where the metal is buried deep
underground which makes it expensive to
extract
that's why comic is returning to
Indonesia where Nicole is found close to
the surface and what that means is that
it's it's actually relatively cheap to
get to you don't have to do some big
sophisticated tunnel system underneath
the ground the problem is that a lot of
the nickel overlaps with forests so when
you're clearing the land what you're
doing is your clearing rainforest
increasingly plants are using a process
called high pressure acid leaching to
extract a nickel from the oil found here
what that involves is subjecting the
nickel to extremely high temperatures
and high pressures
and It ultimately turns it into a
substance that can be used in batteries
this method is about twice as carbon
intensive as other processes used in
Russia or Canada leaving behind large
amounts of waste it's another challenge
for car makers when they're
contemplating sorts of nickel from
Indonesia is that these Islands in
eastern Indonesia are very pristine
they're surrounded by coral reefs if
there's leakage from the nickel into the
reefs that can be quite bad nickel
mining often takes place in remote parts
of the country that are difficult to
access this plant on Obi island is a
full day's Journey from the capital
Jakarta and can only be reached by boat
there are concerns that there isn't that
much oversight over this process and
that the local government departments
although they may intend to enforce
Indonesian environmental law quite
tightly they may really struggle to do
that
a lot of the forest being cleared is
being done legally according to
Indonesian law so it becomes a bit
tricky for companies because there's
ultimately Indonesia and Indonesia is
saying this is okay but if it's okay for
Indonesia's government should that
necessarily mean it's okay for Tesla
these are questions that I think Tesla
is asking Tesla and other automakers
have in recent years dispatched teams to
Indonesia to understand the full scope
of the environmental concerns
despite its toll on the environment
nickel mining has seen explosive growth
in the country Indonesia's government
sees nickel as a way for it to move up
the value chain in 2017 Indonesia was a
minor player in the EV battery nickel
supply chain
but today about half the world's nickel
is mined here they've restricted the
export of nickel so it has to be
processed in country so once the Nickels
processed they're hoping that batteries
will be built in Indonesia may be
exported from Indonesia the cars will be
built in Indonesia that's the Indonesian
government's game plan some analysts
forecast that by 2027 about 80 percent
of the global nickel Supply used in EV
batteries will come from Indonesia to
mitigate the Damage Done by clearing
forests companies have pledged to
replant trees over mined areas and the
government has enforced laws that punish
illegal mining but environmentalists say
corporate planting programs won't
restore the area's unique flora and
fauna it's very difficult and requires a
lot of expertise and a lot of money to
really restore an environment especially
in a delicate ecosystem like this is
there a lot of questions about what
these islands are going to look like 10
years from now
thank you